HE HAD BEEN HELD TO JUST 14
TONIGHT.
GAME RESET, TWO TIMEOUT APIECE.
HAWKS DO INTO A FOUL TO GIVE.
HERE IS DEROZAN.
STOPS, FIRES!
NOT IT!
>> Stacey: OH, MAN!
GOOD OFFENSE RIGHT THERE.
I MEAN, BOGDANOVIC DID ALL HE
COULD DO.
HE STAYED IN FRONT OF HIM.
TRIED TO BE PHYSICAL WITH HIM.
IT'S A BIG STOP HERE.
NOT TO GET A STOP.
>> Adam: ONE-POINT
GAME. DOSUNMU ON YOUNG.
BLOCKED IT!
>> Stacey: TAKE YOUR TIME.
THERE HE IS.
IT'S DEMAR DEROZAN TIME.
LET'S SEE IF THEY DOUBLE-TEAM
HIM, GUEST THE BALL OUT OF HIS
HANDS.
>>> DEROZAN, FIRES FOR THE
LEAD!
GOT IT!
DOES IT AGAIN!
OH, MY GOODNESS!
>> Stacey: I TOLD YOU, DEMAR
DEROZAN TIME!
THEY DIDN'T DOUBLE HIM UNTIL HE
WAS IN THE AIR, ADAM, AND IT
WAS TOO LATE!
ONCE HE GOT TO HIS SPOT, IT WAS
OVER.
LOOK, SPINS BACK, TAKE THAT
WITH YOU.
DEMAR DEROZAN IS THE REAL DEAL.
YOU HEAR THE MVP CHANTS, AND
DESERVEDLY SO.
>> Adam: TWO-POINT BULLS LEAD.
TIME-OUT ATLANTA!
DEMAR WITH THE BIG SHOT IN THE
FOURTH AGAIN!
>> Stacey: HE HAS BEEN THE
BULLS GO-TO PLAYER ALL SEASON.
>> Adam: 37 TONIGHT FOR
DEROZAN.
THAT IS NOW THE SECOND LONGEST
STREAK OF 35-PLUS IN BULLS
HISTORY.
>> Stacey: WATCH THIS.
HERE IT IS.
AGAIN, HUERTER WAS SUPPOSED TO
COME.
HE LEFT ZACH LAVINE.
IN THEY WEREN'T EVEN WORRIED
ABOUT ZACH LAVINE HITTING THE
THREE-POINT SHOT.
THEY KNEW THAT DEMAR DEROZAN
WAS GOING TO BE THE GUY, SO
THEY LEFT ZACH LAVINE AND SAID
IF YOU BEAT US WITH A THREE,
WE'RE NOT GOING TO LET DEMAR
DEROZAN GETS THE SHOT, BUT THEY
DID TIGHT LATE.
DEMAR SAW THE TRAP, SPUN AWAY
FROM IT, AND GOT THE BUCKET AND
THE FOUL, AS WELL.
>> Adam: WHAT'S THE WORD WE
USED EARLIER, PLEA SIX.
EVERYTHING ABOUT DEMAR DEROZAN
IS PRECISE.
IT MAY NOT LOOK IT IN TERMS OF
SPEED, PUT HE PLAYS AT HIS OWN
PACE, AND NOBODY CAN RUSH WHAT
DEROZAN CAN DO.
>> Stacey: HERE IT IS RIGHT
HERE.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO COMMIT, IF
YOUR HUERTER, YOU HAVE TO GO!
DON'T GO HALFWAY ON DEMAR
DEROZAN!
HAVE YOU NOT BEEN WATCHING
DEMAR DEROZAN ALL SEASON LONG!